Russia as you'll be aware is huge
growing from a medium-sized state in the
mid 16th century to this in the
mid-1700s most of these lands are in
what's called Siberia which were
difficult to govern due to their sheer
size and place Russia in contact with
more potential Rivals as such this
raises the question why did Russia
conquer Siberia what did it have to gain
from doing so well it won't surprise you
to know that the primary reason was
money as of the reign of Ivan the
Terrible moscow's lifeblood was trade
often infers these were sourced from the
neighboring lands and states which often
came into conflict with Moscow in 1552
Ivan conquered the carnate of Kazan and
soon afterwards the Astra Khan carnate
these conquests were both primarily to
give Moscow control of the Volga River
and thus the Region's trade routes so
with the economic lifeblood of Moscow
secured along with some new fancy
farmland and peasants there to tax why
did Ivan and his successes push for more
well Ivan sent a man called
yermaktimavevich to lead an army of
Cossacks to pacify the neighboring
states and he did this for two reasons
the first was to prevent raiding into
moscow's territories and the second was
to extract tribute in the form of Furs
which would then be sold onto Europe
after the Russians conquered severe from
which Siberia gets its name there was
little in the way of organized
resistance left which as a result meant
that it only took 60 years for Moscow to
conquer all of this and it made its way
there because frankly nobody could stop
them and for the SARS of Russia
expansion only had upsides Siberia was
cheap to govern because it basically
wasn't governed Russia planted trading
posts and small fortresses along the
frontier which existed to protect roads
and River crossings from Raiders as for
most of the people who lived in Siberia
many had little idea that they now lived
in a place called Russia in fact in much
of siberia's North Russian influence was
basically non-existent and some parts of
it wouldn't be fully mapped until the
Soviet Union carried out its censuses
it's just that the Russians claimed it
and the people who made the maps weren't
exactly going to argue with them
eventually the Russians would run into a
major power which wanted to expand into
the region the Qing Dynasty when they
first came into contact the Qing were
quick to shoot at the Russians until
they left local leaders continued
fighting until leadership in Moscow
formally sued for peace it was agreed
that in return for some limited trade
access Russia would renounce any claim
to these lands and acknowledge Qing
ownership after both sites had agreed it
wasn't long before the Russians took
everything to the north again this was
because nothing was stopping them and
it's not like it cost the government
much to do so also Russia was now about
20 times as large as it had been a
century prior and its sheer size and by
extension Prestige was one of the
reasons that European leaders
acknowledged Russian SARS becoming
Russian Emperors when China would later
find itself on the receiving end of
European Imperial policy Russia was
quick to capitalize and it took the
lands it had previously been denied
meaning that the country would stretch
all the way from the Baltic Sea in the
west to the Sea of Japan in the East I
hope you enjoyed this episode and a
special thanks to my patrons James
bisonet Kelly moneymaker Sky Chappelle
Corso wolf Jerry lambdin Jordan Longley
Adam Stalter Marcus Arsenal YN hockey
Spencer Lightfoot rod D Martin words
about books podcast Captain side dog
Gustav Swan Marvin Cassel commune
Winston K wood boogly Wiggly Daniel
tobian Miss is it Aaron the white Corey
Turner the mcwhopper Alex Schwinn
Anthony Beckett Coppertone Maggie
Paskowski she went in spinning three
plates and Charles the first